los hospitales de manaos la capital del
amazonas brasileño llevan días sin
oxígeno esto obligó a la fuerza aérea
brasileña a hacer cuatro vuelos diarios
desde el estado vecino de para cargados
del suplemento pero aún así es
insuficiente para abastecer los 76 mil
metros cúbicos que se requieren
diariamente en el estado el ministerio
de salud brasileño sostiene que manaus
nunca ha tenido una buena red
hospitalaria y que ahora se suman los
pacientes que no atendieron antes a
causa de la paleta digamos un impacto
tenemos un impacto de las cirugías y los
tratamientos de salud que se pospusieron
a lo largo de 2020 postergado lo windows
beach somos makudi
sumado al kobe y al colapso del sistema
de salud de managua
y manaus
la falta de oxígeno obligó a muchas
personas a salir a las calles para
comprar pipetas para sus seres queridos
que están hospitalizados aunque no todos
logran encontrarlo en medio de la
escasez venezuela envió seis tanques con
136 mil litros de oxígeno y aunque el
gobernador de amazonas aseguró que es
una de las cargas más significativas que
han recibido en esta segunda crisis
hospitalaria el presidente brasileño ya
ir bolsonaro hizo mofa de lemona
no hay más allá no hay perros porque una
plaga se comieron todos los perros y los
gatos y hay algunos idiotas diciendo
miren a maduro de gran corazón
imaginen ese tamaño 200 kilos 2 metros
su corazón debe ser muy grande ahora si
maduro quiere darnos oxígeno lo podemos
recibir sin ningún problema
el podría darle ayuda de emergencia a su
gente el salario mínimo no alcanza ni
para lograr un medio de arroz pues la
segunda ola de la pandemia golpea tan
fuerte a manaos que el lunes fue el
segundo municipio que más casos registró
en todo brasil